claro y es que los encargados del
impeachment en el senado le enviaron una
carta a el expresidente donald trump
refiriéndole que fuera a testificar en
audiencia pública a los abogados les
respondieron inmediatamente los abogados
de donald trump una carta a los
administradores del imperio en
diciéndole que no que el ex el ex
presidente no se va a presentar
simplemente porque ellos no creen que
hubo delito porque no creen
específicamente que el presidente al
decir que leen como en el infierno en el
discurso antes de que los manifestantes
se tomaran el capitolio el 6 de enero
pues incitó entonces a que ellos se
tomaran el capitolio no hay conexión
dicen sus abogados ahí por ende es
inconstitucional la el juicio político
que tienen hacerle a donald trump y por
ende no se va a presentar dicen que
simplemente no tienen base y pues se
preparan entonces con el expresidente
alegando precisamente eso saben además
su defensa la defensa del expresidente
trump
van a contar los demócratas con dos
tercios de los votos en el senado que se
necesita para aprobar el impeachment
quizás gracias por la información